one more from AOC because Clarence
Thomas really went after katanji Brown
Jackson
in one of his briefings and I thought it
was quite you'll see well he's giving
you Thomas soul level stuff here and uh
AOC ain't having it
here is part of what Justice Thomas
wrote he said quote Justice Jackson uses
her broad observations about statistical
relationships between race and select
measures of health wealth and well-being
to label all blacks as victims her
desire to do so is unfathomable to me it
is an insult to individual achievement
and cancerous to Young Minds seeking to
push through barriers their race is not
to blame for everything good or bad that
happens in their lives what is your
response to that
I mean what Justice Clarence Thomas
wrote there I believe is profoundly
disrespectful
um to to I just think it was profoundly
disrespectful to his colleague it
includes sweeping uh assumptions about
her world view whereas when you look at
what
um what the response was from Justice
katanji Brown we saw that her descent
was grounded in fact it was grounded in
the facts of the case for him to come
out and insinuate that her opinion is
due to
some sort of
inferior or less than uh you know less
than than
really thought out of a stance I think
it's profoundly insulting you're
profoundly insulting you brain dead
Dullard what Thomas said very clearly in
in all of his remarks right because they
have to write basically essays
explaining their decisions right and
they're also allowed to write about the
dissenters and the dissenters are
allowed to write about the people who
are on the other side of it that's how
that's how the whole thing works if you
think for one second that Clarence
Thomas wasn't thought out when he was
criticizing katanji Brown Jackson
katanji Brown Jackson is doing
Progressive 101 right that skin color
matters more than anything else that we
should destroy meritocracy in the name
of collectivism that we should pick
winners and losers etc etc so he's not
he's not going after her in a way that
is unjust what AOC does not like is that
katanji brown Jackson and AOC are on the
wrong side of this thing and most people
know it right I mean I get that there is
like this hysterical never-ending
screeching AOC style mainstream media
person who demands that we look at
everyone's race and is obsessed with
everyone's genitals and everything else
but the average person when that court
order came down last week I really think
the average person was just looked at it
for anyone who's just paying attention
you know not the most hyper political
people the average person was like yeah
we shouldn't be discriminating and we
should stop punishing Asian kids and we
should stop punishing white kids and if
there were any laws that were stopping
Black
kids from getting into schools then sure
we should look at that we should not
have any discrimination but you have to
understand these people are upset that
people are allowed to make choices like
the the issue with the web designer in
Colorado they are upset that people who
make bad choices say getting a whole
bunch of student loans to go to Syracuse
to get a useless degree in
Communications uh have to pay the price
for that and they are upset that
discrimination will not be part of the
college admissions admissions process
this is the backwards way they look at
everything
yeah
foreign
[Music]